[موسيقى]
ام ام
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء قال تقرير صادر
عن مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي ان قمع السلطات المصريه
لمعارضيها حاليا لن يجلب الاستقرار
السياسي للبلاد
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
مدى موضوعيه ما جاء في التقرير ودلالات
صدوره قبيل الاستفتاء على التعديلات
الدستوريه
وهل يمكن ان يؤدي التقرير الى تغيير في
سياسه الاتحاد الاوروبي اتجاه الحكومه
المصريه
اذن تشغل الاوضاع في مصر حيزا مهما في ذهن
صانع القرار الاوروبي عند تناول قضايا
الشرق الاوسط
وتقرير مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه عن مصر
يمثل محاوله اوروبيه
توصيف الوضع في مصر سعيا لتحديد خطه
التعامل في المرحله المقبله
التقرير يحمل المسؤوليه عن تفاقم الوضع
للسلطات متهما اياها باستخدام القبضه
الامنيه بقسوه بينما ترى اطراف مصريه ان
حركه الاخوان المسلمين هي المسؤول الاول
عن ما الت اليه التطورات
القمع في مصر غير قابل للاستمرار حكي عن
مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
تقريرا مطولا عن مصر بعد سته اشهر من
اطاحه العسكر بالرئيس المنتخب وجهت تقرير
جوله انتقادات للسلطه الانتقاليه المعينه
من قبل الجيش واشار الى ان القمع الذي
تمارسه السلطات ضد جماعه الاخوان لم يجلب
الاستقرار للبلاد نموها كتب التقرير الى
ان صوره تحقيق حاله من الاستقرار التي
تسوقها السلطه الانتقاليه غير صحيحه وقال
ان مصر لن تكون قادره على العوده ل لو صار
الديمقراطي وتحقيق حكم مستقر في الوقت
الذي تستمر فيه عمليات اجتثاث الاخوان
المسلمين كمنظمه
استمرار قمع الاصوات المعارضه وفق التقرير
يؤدي الى حل ينهي الانقسام السياسي
والاجتماعي الذي تعيشه البلاد بناء على
هذه المعطيات تدعي تقرير المجلس دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي للتعامل مع مصر بنظره
بعيده المدى ترتكز على العناصر الاساسيه
التي تؤدي عاجلا ام اجلا الى انبثاق اطار
سياسي مستقر واوضح التقرير ان الاتحاد
يواجه الكثير من التحديات حول كيفيه دعم
التحول السياسي في مصر دون دعم غير مشروط
لخريطه الطريق التي وضعتها السلطه
الانتقاليه سلطه وبعد الاستفتاء على
الدستور الجديد ستشرع في التحضير
لانتخابات رئاسيه وبرلمانيه رغم الوضع
الامني غير المستقر في الموازنه مع ذلك
مظاهره تبقى من انصار الرئيس المعزول خارج
السجن عاده ما تنتهي ب اشتباكات مع قوى
الامن تنتظر مصر مواعيد مهمه من استحقاقات
انتخابيه الى محاكمات مثيره للجدل وللاسف
عنفا يغيب عن المشهد قريبا
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من لندن
عبر سكايب انطوني دور كبير الباحثين في
المجلس الاوروبي للعلاقات الخارجيه واحد
مؤدي التقرير وهنا اه نستضيف الاستوديو
هاني رسلان رئيس تحرير ملف الاهرام
الاستراتيجى
مرحبا بك السيد هاني وابدا مع انطوني دور
كان من لندن سيد انطوني التقرير الصادر عن
مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وصف الوضع القائم وانتهى الى
خلاصات وتوصيات لكنه لم يوصف الاصل وهو
الحكم القائم حاليا في مصر وهو شرعي ام
غير شرعي من وجهه نظر الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيد انطوني
انقطع الاتصال مع انطوني دورتين سنعود
اليه طبعا انتقل الى ضيفي في الاستوديو
هاني رسلان سيد هني اولا ما هو تعليقك على
ما ورد في هذا التقرير
اه في الحقيقه انا كنت اه اود الاطلاع
بشكل كامل على نص التقرير ولكن لم يسعفني
الوقت وتصفحته بشكل سريع واعتقد انه قد
بذل فيه جهد اه كبير اه في اه محاوله
دراسه و توصيف وتحليل الاوضاع في مصر ولكن
ايضا لدي مجموعه من الملاحظات على هذا
التقرير اه اول هذه الملاحظات ان التقرير
احيانا يستند الى بعض المعطيات التي تبدو
متناقضه بمعنى انه يقول اه او يقر بان
السلطه الانتقاليه القائمه في مصر مدعومه
الان من غالبيه الشعب المصري ويقول في
مقطع اخر ايضا ان الدستور اه ال او مش
مشروع مسوده الدستور الحاليه اه ت يعني
تحمل في اه اجزاء كبيره منها تقدما كبيرا
قياسا الى الدستور السابق الذي يقرر ايضا
انه كان تلافيا ولكنه في نفس الوقت يقول
بان المسار الحالي هو مسار امني ويقول بان
السلطات تحظر جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
تعتبرها ارهابيه
وفي ال في الحقيقه لم يظهر الجانب الاخر
من ممارسات تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين في
الشارع الامر الذي دفع السلطه القائمه
لاتخاذ هذا الاجراء هذه النقطه النقطه
الثانيه ايضا يبدو ان واضعي التقرير يتحدث
عن الاخوان المسلمين كتيار عام تتسم بقدر
من التركيب بمعنى ان هناك تنظيم قائم فيه
اعضاء عاملون ملتزمون بالسمع والطاعه
وهناك مؤيدون وهناك انصار هو ياخذ الجميع
اه اه في سياق واحد لكن قرار الحظر في
الحقيقه كان موجها فقط ضد التنظيم ومن
يرتبطون به في اعمال اه تهدد اه الاوضاع
الامنيه غير غير منهم
في التنظيم هم تردون ايضا
غير متعودين على الاطلاق هناك الكثير من
هم في حركات خارج اطار الاخوان المسلمين
لكن هم معارضون للحرب انهم غير مطار دين
ولا يعتبر في مصر القرار الصادر اه اه
جماعه ارهابيه اه لان النص واضح هو من
يرتبط بالتنظيم او يساعده اه في ارتكاب
الاعمال التي تؤدي العدم الاستقرار نريد
ان اقول فقط ان قرار الحظر هو ضد التنظيم
فقط وليس ضد المؤيدين والانصار ولا ضد
التيار الاسلامي دعني اعود الى سيد انطوني
دور كان سيد انطوني كنت سالتك عن توصيف
الوضع القائم في مصر حاليا من حيث اسباغ
الشرعيه عليه املا من وجهه نظر مجلس
العلاقات الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
لابد اولا ان اوضح شيئا هاما وهو اني اعمل
في منظمه المستقله اه ال المجلس الاوروبي
للعلاقات الخارجيه وهو مركز بحوث اه له
حسب رايي بعض التاثير على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن لان نقول ان تكلم باسم
الاتحاد بل نقدم له المشهوره فقط ولكن انا
درست بشكل جيد مواقف وتصرفات الاتحاد
الاوروبي ازاء تطورات الوضع في مصر منذ
النهضه ضد الانتفاضه ضد الرئيس مبارك قبل
ثلاث سنوات
وطبعا الاحداث التي حصلت في الصيف الماضي
حيث اقام الجيش بتنحيه رئيس منافي من
السلطه ان موقف الاتحاد الاوروبي حسب رايي
وموقف هو انهم لم يرغبوا في ان
ان يهاجم هجوما مباشرا شرعيه هذا النظام
بل فضلوا ان يعني فقط يتحدث عن الاجراءات
الضروريه تقوم بها مثله تمضي قدما الى
الامام
لذلك قام الاتحاد الاوروبي بالدعوه الى
اه اه الى حمايه جميع الاجراءات اللازمه
الى التطور السياسي والى انتخابات نزيهه
كما دعا الاتحاد الاوروبي الى اجراءات
لمحاوله تقرير اعمال العنف من الجانبين
وايضا تطبيق حكم القانون
للمقاطعه سيد انطوني عفوا للمقاطعه افهم
منك هنا اه بانكم تفضلون ان لا تدخلوا في
هذا المضمار ونقاش شرعيه او عدم شرعيه
الحكم القائم على اعتبار ان هذا ما صار
عليه الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد اسقاط
الرئيس حسني مبارك ضيفي في الاستوديو هنا
كان يتحدث قبل قليل عن عدم موضوعيه في بعض
النقاط التي تحدثتم عنها في التقرير بحيث
انكم تحدثت مع ما يجري للاخوان المسلمين
من دون ان تتحدث عن الاسباب التي ادت الى
وصولهم الى حد وضعهم على لائحه ارهابيه من
قبل الحكومه المصريه
في الحقيقه ما اقوله انه عده امور اولا
وبشكل لا لبس فيه انا اعتقد ان الرئيس
مرسي ارتكب اخطاء اثناء فتره حكمه وانا
بالتاكيد انتقدت ه اه في حول طريقه دارته
في شؤون البلاد وطريقه اه قيام حزب
العداله الحريه والعداله التابع الاخوه
الفلسطينيين بالتصرف اثناء تلك الفتره لكن
لما شهد او او اي دليل يوحي بالقول بانه
يمكن وصفهم بانهم منظمه ارهابيه
حسب رايي اعتقد ان هذا التصريح صادره من
الحكومه دون اي دليل وان موقف الدول
الاوروبيه في الوقت الحالي ليس هو وصف
الاخوان المسلمين على انه منظمه ارهابيه
لانهم لم يشاهدوا اي دليل على ذلك هو حسب
وجهه نظر خاصه انا
عميق وشديد ازاء بعض الاجراءات التي تقوم
بها الحكومه الامريكي عفوا المصريه منذ
هذا الوقت
اذ انهم يرفضون قيودا شديده على حريه
التعبير وقد تعتقل واعداد كبيره من الناس
من المتابعين الاخوان المسلمين دون ان
يكون هناك ادله على ذلك في جميع الحالات
وتاتي القانونيه ويبدو ان ما قاموا به هو
عباره عن هجوم واسع شديد دو على الاخوان
المسلمين دون هناك ادله واضحه
يقدمونها لتبرير ذلك التصرف اذن انا اؤكد
بانه يؤيد الاجراءات التي تتخذ اذا ما كان
هناك ادله على ان هناك التحريض على العنف
او القيام باعمال عنف ولا اعتقد ان ما حصل
في مصر امر يتجاوز ذلك ويبدو ان الامر
عباره عن حمله سياسيه الهدف منها اه انهاء
وغلق ايه مساحه الاوسع في ال في السياسه
يمكن الاخوان المسلمين الشكل العام العمل
فيها ذلك انه على اساس كل ما شاهدته لحد
الان اجد ان كل ما اختلف من اجراءات غير
مبرر سيد هاني كل ما اتخذ من اجراءات غير
مبرر وليس هناك اي دليل هذا ما يقوله معد
هذا اه او احد معديه هذا التقرير الذي هو
بين يدي الامر اه اولا في الحقيقه انا
اشعر بالدهشه من هذا الاستنتاج الذي وصل
اليه لانه كما ذكرت قبل قليل اه الاخوان
المسلمين تيار مركب ال الوصف بالمنظمه
الارهابيه كان بحق التنظيم وليس بحق
متعاطفين او المؤيدين او الانصار وهذا
التنظيم مازال حتى هذه اللحظه رغم انه كان
قد وصل الى الحكم لمده عام في مصر يعمل
كمنظمه سريه وهذه المنظمه السريه يسيطر
عليها الجناح المتشدد الذي يعرف باسم
الجناح القطبي وهذا الجناح القطبي في صلب
افكاره اللجوء الى السيد ان صلى يقول ان
ما اقدر عليه السلطه حاليا كان يحتاج الى
دليل وهو قال ربما نؤيد هذه الاجراءات لو
قدمت ادله اه في الحقيقه هذا رايي الشخصي
ولكن المؤتمر الاخير لوزير الداخليه شاهده
اه تقديم ادله واعترافات مصوره واه اه عرض
متهمين ينتمون الى تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين
ساهموا بالذات في حادث المنصوره الذي ادى
الى قتل مدنيين وقتل من عدد من رجال
الشرطه النقطه الثانيه ايضا وهو ربما قد
تابع ذلك بحكم ان الورقه بها كثير من
التفاصيل اه في اه اه رابعه العدويه قبل
ثوره الثلاثين من يونيو اه كان هناك
تهديدا تصريحه بسحق المعارضين وهذا
التنظيم يعتبر معارضيه اه اما منافقين او
كفار وبالتالي هو اصلا خارج الفكره
الديمقراطيه هو معوق للمسار الديمقراطي و
اه اه اه كان هذا بحضور الرئيس محمد مرسي
وكانت التهديدات علنيه في ميدان رابعه
العدويه
وبعد ذلك صدرت عده تصريحات تربط ربطا
مباشرا بين الارهاب الذي يحدث في سيناء
وبين تنظيم الاخوان او عوده الرئيس موسى
النقطه الثانيه ان الحكومه المصريه اعطت
هذا التنظيم فرصه سته اشهر قبل ان تصل الى
هذا اه القرار اه لكي يكون هناك مجال
للتفاوض وتم دعوتها عده مرات ولكن تنظيم
اعرب عن ذلك ولم يقدم اي مطالب عقود لم
يقدم اي مطالب معقوله تدخل يعني على
العمليه السلام على الرغم من ذلك يعني ما
قدم غير مقنع كان ل اه المعديه التقرير
وايضا شرائح واسعه من الشعب المصري او
غيره ايضا لكن في هذه النقطه اريد ان
انتقل مجددا الى السيد انطوني لاساله سيد
انطوني ماذا عن توقيت اصدار هذا التقرير
لماذا الان والبعض ربطه ب اه
تزامنه مع
التحضير او بدء الاستفتاء على الدستور
الجديد
هذا صحيح نحن نشرنا التقرير في هذا
التوقيت
لانه هذا هو الوقت الذي سيتجه في
الاستفتاء حول الدستور
وتكون هناك سلسله من الانتخابات بعد ذلك
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه بعد ذلك
ولا نعرض الضبط تسلسل هما ولكن على الارجح
يبدو ان تكون هناك انتخابات رئاسيه اولا
واذن فان الصوره التي تقدمها السلطات
المصريه هي صوره العوده الى اللغه الطبيعي
والاعتيادي اننا نرحب التاكيد
باجراء استفتاء ين
وانتخابات ولكن ما نوضحها هنا في تقديرنا
هو ان هذا ليس ان هذه ليست الصوره الكامله
ان تكون لديك الديمقراطيه ونحن نؤمن تكون
لديك اولا استقرار في مصر ويجب ان يكون
لديك ليس فقط تصويت وانتخابات بلك لديك
ظروفه
تمكن جميع فئات المجتمع المصري واراء
والتيارات السياسيه المشاركه في العمليه
السياسيه
توفر حريه التعبير بحيث ان الطرفين يستطيع
ان ان يقدم رايهم ا وان يتمكن الناس
بتنظيم حملات ضد الدستور او او او مع
الدستور
وما نحاول ان نوضح وفي تقديرنا هو ان هناك
بعض القلق حول حول هل ان هذه الظروف توفر
ام لا لا اود القول باننا ندين كل ما يحصل
في مصر فالدستور حسب رايي اه فيه بعض
الجوانب الجيده ولا
وايضا لا و د الدفاع عن كل ما اه اه يقوم
او قام بها الرئيس مرسي او ب قام بها
اخوان المسلمون اثناء فتره حكمه ولكن اننا
لم نرى الا وكل ما شاهدناه هي تتهم جزئي
جراء اجراميه ضد الاخوان المسلمين ومن
يدافع عنهم ولم نشاهد اي محاولات ي منظمه
لدراسه كل الحالات التي حصل في حالات قتل
وفاه كثيره وذلك انه كان كثير من الحالات
قبل وصول الرئيس مرسى الى الحكم واعتقد
اننا نرحب بك
حول ما حصل في رابعه العدويه
وما سبقها ذلك سيد سيد انتوني ايضا اعتذر
للمقاطعه لضيق الوقت لكن كل ما عرضته
سنسال في القسم الثاني من هذه الحلقه ان
كان سيؤدي الى تغيير في سياسه الاتحاد
الاوروبي تجاه الحكومه المصريه الحاليه
نرجو ان تقوم معنا مشاهدينا القسم الثاني
ام
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تقرير مجلس العلاقات الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي عن ان القمع في مصر لن
يجلب الاستقرار واعود الى ضيفي في
الاستوديو السيد هاني رسلان سيد هاني اه
ضيفنا قبل قليل من لندن تحدث عن ان الجو
الحالي في مصر لا يساعد ابدا على اجراء
استفتاء او انتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه
باعتبار ان ما يجري في الشارع اه لا يدفع
الى الاطمئنان وفي الحقيقه تحدث عن اه ما
يقول انه حريه التعبير بشكل كافي لتنظيم
حملات لمن يعترضون على الاستفتاء وانا
اعتقد ان معلوماته في هذا الموضوع تحتاج
الى مراجعه لان هنا ان نعرف ان تحالف ما
يسمى تحالف دعم الشرعيه المؤيد لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين يعمل من داخل مصر و يعقد
مؤتمراته الصحفيه ويصدر بياناته وهناك عده
صحف اه تصدر عن القوى المؤيده لهذا
التحالف وحتى قريب كانت تصدر ايضا صحيفه
الحريه والعداله المعبره عن حزب الحريه
والعداله المنتمي للاخوان المسلمين فبد
وايضا هناك حركه الت ابريل تعلن رفضها
للاستفتاء للدستور وتدعو لمقاطعه وهي تعمل
ايضا في اه اه مصر ولا احد يعترض ها في
هذا اه الامر النقطه الثانيه هو يصل الى
استنتاج بان العمليه السياسيه لا تستوعب
كل الاطراف ويقصد بذلك تنظيم الاخوان
المسلمين ولكنه لم يدلنا كيف يمكن استيعاب
هذا التنظيم الذي يرفض الانخراط في
العمليه السياسيه ويستخدم العنف في
الشوارع وشو راينا كيف قاموا بذبح احد
المواطنين في المنصوره بشكل في مشهد
ماساوي وايضا لا يقدمون اي مطالب سياسيه
اه معقوله تصلح للتفاوض او لانخراطهم في
العمليه السياسيه سوى اعاده الرئيس
المعزول لكي يقوم باعدام ما يسمى ما
يسمونه بالانقلابيين في حين ان اه الورقه
نفسها تقول بان السلطه الانتقاليه الحاليه
وهذا توصيف دقيق مدعومه من غالبيه الشعب
المصري فاين هو الخلل او هذه المطالب او
هذه النداءات من جانبه يجب ان توجه يعني
انت قبل ما ما يؤيد وجهه نظرك وترفض في
التقرير مالا
يؤيد وجهات يا استاذ حسن انا ا سرد
الوقائع التي تقول بان الواقع الواقع
الغاء في مصر
ليست صفه الورقه واقول بانه يجب ان يؤدي
نجاته الى تنظيم الاخوان وليس الى تلقيه
اعود الى السيد ان ترى سيد انطوني اه الى
اي مدى يمكن ان يؤثر
تقريركم هذا على السياسه الاوروبيه اه
اتجاه مصر
انا اعتقد ان الكثير من الاوروبيين يشعرون
بقلق عندما ينظرون الى مصر اليوم قومي
الشعر ون الذي قد جاء بعض القضايا التي
ناقشناها في تقريرنا وهم يشعرون بقلق حول
هل انه هناك محاوله
لتاسيس نظام سياسي مفتوح بشكل اصيل وحقيقي
امام كل المجموعات
الاجراءات المتخذه ضد الاخوان المسلمين
وكذلك في الوقت ذاته طبعا اه علاقاته
اوروبا ومصر علاقات مهمه جدا وهم يدركون ب
حقيقه وواقعا هذا النظام الحالي هو الذي
في السلطه ويفهمون هناك اي مجال لعودته
واملي عوده مرسيل الحكومه وبالتالي
يحاولون التوفيق بين الشيئين اي التعامل
مع السلطات الموجوده لك لديهم علاقات جيده
بناءه معها وحوار جيد مع السلطات ومع
محاوله استخدام النفوذ الذي لديهم نحو
الوصول الى اسلوب اكثر شموليه في الحكومه
واذا رفع بعض القيود المفروضه و بعض
الاجراءات القمعيه الاخرى التي اتخذت
وبالتالي اعتقد هذا هو موقف اوروبا
سيد سيد انطوني عذرا سيد انطوني باختصار
انتم دعوته الى تغيير
السياسه الاوروبيه في مصر في اي اتجاه
تدعونا الى تغيير هذه السياسه
اعتقد ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يحاول ان يوازن
بين شيئين
الموازنه بين القاع العلاقات الجيده مع
السلطات المصريه وايضا في الوقت ذاته
تعزيز الرؤيه التي يرونها افضل رؤيه لمصر
في المستقبل واعتقد انه لحد الان يميلون
الى الكلام بطريقه لينه وبسيطه واستخدام
نفوذهم في وراء الكواليس
اعتقد الوقت غير الملائم الان ان تتخذ
موقفا قويا وان تؤكد على ما يرون انه ال
ال الحدود الخطر في الاسبوع الحالي وان
يكونوا واضحين بشكل اكبر حول الخطوات
اللازمه والضروريه حسب راي ال اوروبا لكي
تمضي قدما الى الامام نحو مستقبل ديمقراطي
السيد هنيه هل تتوقع اي تغيير في السياسه
ال ال اه المصريه سياسه الحكومه الحاليه
اتجاه معارضيها في ظل استمرار تقارير من
هذا النوع تقارير دوليه تصدر من هذا النوع
اه كل المعارضين في مصر لهم الحق في العمل
بحريه وهم موجودون ويعملون الان ومن صدر
بحقهما اجراءات قضائيه او اه قرار من مجلس
الوزراء باعتبار التنظيم الارهابيين وال
تنظيم الاخوان المسلمين الذي هو منظمه اه
اه سريه واقول بان مصر اه وبكل فئاتها
الاجتماعيه وقواه السياسيه كان لديها امل
كبير في التقدم نحو تحول ديمقراطي حقيقي
ولكننا نفاجئ ب اه فصيل سياسي يقول اه ب
اه اه يعني اه تطبيقات معينه في افكاره يا
اما ان يحكم اما ان يقتل الناس وهذه مشكله
كبرى تقف عقبه في طريقه حول الذي اريد انا
اعود بسؤال مختصر للسيد انطوني ماذا
تقترحون انتم من تغيير للاتحاد الاوروبي
اعتقد انه سيكون هذا اولا موضوع الرساله
التي تبعثها اوروبا الى السلطات المصريه
فيما يقول انه خلف الكواليس وايضا قليلا
حول ما يكون بشكل علني واعتقد ان الرساله
ربما ينبغي ان تكون تعبيرا عن قلق اكبر
حول الاتجاه الذي تسير فيه الامور حاليا
وكذلك تاكيد اكبر على الخطوات اللازمه
اتخاذها
لكي يكون السير حسب الى تجاه افضل حسب
رايي طبعا نحن نفهم ان الوضع في مصر اه
معقد للغايه
وانا لا ادعو الى مره مبسطه يمكن اه نقول
فيه ان كلمات والاخوان المسلمون جيدا لا
يبدو لان الخطوات المتخذه ضدهم قد تجاوزت
الى حد كبير الاسس التي قد تكون موجوده ل
لاي خطوات يمكن ان تتخذ وحسب فهمي
لانه الرغم ان الموقف الاساسي الاخوان
المسلمين هو المطالبه باعاده الرئيس مرسيل
الحكم الها الان تجاوزوا هذا الموقف
مستعدون القديم الموضوع من التنازلات
وقبوله واقع ما حصل ولكن هذا الصباح شكرا
جزيلا اعتذر للمقاطعه انتهى وقتنا سيد
انطوني دور كبير الباحثين في المجلس
الاوروبي للعلاقات الخارجيه
واشكر في الاستوديو ايضا هاني رسلان رئيس
تحرير ملف الاهرام الاستراتيجيه شكرا
لمتابعتكم مشاهدينا والى
ام
[موسيقى]